i'm making this video to address the
ongoing back and forth between myself
and drake kanye west is making a peace
offering to drake following the rapper's
long-standing feud both me and drake
have taken shots at each other and it's
time to put it to rest in this video
posted by music executive jay prince who
you see on the right the donda rapper
reads a message off his cell phone
directly addressing drake and
acknowledging the success of his most
recent album certified loverboy
i'm asking drake on december 7 to join
me on stage as a special guest to share
the two biggest hours of the year
live in los angeles with the ultimate
purpose being to free larry hoover larry
hoover is the co-founder of chicago's
gangster disciples gang he's currently
serving a life sentence in federal
prison after he was found guilty of
murder in 1973.
in jay prince's caption he mentions that
he met with kanye to pass on a message
from hoover that message to see peace
between the two musicians i believe this
event will not only bring awareness to
our cause but prove to people everywhere
how much more we can accomplish when we
lay our pride to decide and come
together
during the 44 year old's recent drink
champs interview he talks about his feud
with drake and how he believes the nice
for what rapper approaches his rat beefs
like war
drake don't
do a dis like outright dis song where
it's a head shot he's gonna
set up set it up like war he's gonna do
stuff like live five blocks down the
street from you
dm everything is that yeah yeah are you
talking you're gonna like go and you
know
dm every single
girl in your family every single girl
around your family on drake's certified
lover boy album he seemingly took shots
at kanye and the song 7 a.m on brittle
path stemming from an alleged and now
deleted instagram post in august where
kanye appeared to share drake's toronto
address you know the fourth level of
jealousy is called media isn't that an
ironic revelation get that address to
your driver make it your destination
instead of just a post out of
desperation their ongoing feud which was
speculated to have started around 2010
reached a new level in 2018 when kanye
revealed on instagram that he was upset
over drake's hit and my feelings which
mentions a woman named kiki
also happens to be kanye's now estranged
wife kim kardashian's well-known
nickname the song sparked rumors that
drake and kim may have been more than
friends at some point but kim wasted no
time shutting down the speculation on
instagram writing quote never happened
end of story i'll voice my opinion when
i think that there's something that you
know has made me done wrong back in 2018
it spoke with the mother of four about
the drama that kanye sometimes finds
himself in i've seen him go through
a lot and he's just the most genuine
person and you know he might say things
that might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it but i
always know his heart we have different
views sometimes we have different
things but that's my husband you know